thank you for joining me my name is
peter nagy i'm from university of
kentucky i'm a professor at plant
pathology department
today presentation is the title is virus
replication the role of the unique
pathogenic organelle
virus is in fact the different kingdoms
of life including
people
shown here the kovid
knight in causing sarsko virus on the
top
and also the mosquito bone zika virus
for example and african swine fever
virus avian influenza virus
these are causing diseases in animals
but plants also getting sick uh during
uh
from viruses as shown on the on the
right
uh most of the viruses are having rna
genomes these viruses they don't have
dna
but only the rna to code for
proteins and these viruses replicate
inside the cell as shown
these vices in use membranous
compartments these are the virus
replication organelles shown for
hepatitis c virus on the left
or polio virus and insect viruses like
fluke house virus and also the plant
infecting tomato bushes stand right
today my presentation will focus on a
tomato bushestone virus which is the
modal virus infecting tobacco tomato and
several other plants
these virus uh
codes just having one single rna genome
so this is similar to source code ii
which also has just one single
rna genome but
tbsv short for tomato burst and virus is
much much solar smaller than uh source
cov2 it only has 5000 uh
nucleotides it codes for five proteins
p33 is an rna chaperone
and p92 is the the one which is copying
the rna
and making a lot of copies of the rna
during infection these two proteins p37
p92 are required for replication of the
virus
the other proteins p41 the code protein
this incapacitates the viral irony as
shown in the very left to the veins in
an electron microscope image
and the other proteins are involved in
cell to cell movement and
responses to
the plant uh rnai response
we were able to develop a yeast as a
model for this plant virus by using
plasmid-based
expression of proteins and the viral rna
and this results in a
replication of the viral rna inside the
east side as shown now in the boxed area
the very high level of replication takes
place this allows us to use yeast cell
biology tools
genetic tools and also the biochemistry
so
in plant cells tbsc uses the large
replication organelles the blue on the
left shows uh the wire replication
protein p33 inside the cell within the
replication organelle
and
the green one is the host factor you can
see
and red one is the viral iron in the
center it is are colloquialized as you
can see on the merged image on the very
left
very right
and so these are very large organelles
they are about five to ten micrometer in
size in inside the plant cells and this
is about the size of the nucleus as well
so this is the place where the virus
replication takes place and today i'm
going to entertain you about how
important is this the formation of this
application we're going gonna have
uh
tbsp
forms this replication organization
yeast and this this is the tomographic
image
prepared in collaboration with christian
orisko in
in madrid
and as you can see on the right
the blue ones are the viral replication
complexes these are small pharaohs and
you see several of them
this is uh in a
peroxisome membrane which is the yellow
one
and then also you can see the gold one
is the er membrane
and
so this this together this is the
replication organelle
and this is forming during replication
so as i mentioned yeast allowed us to
utilize a lot of tools which is
available in yeast to identify host
factors because this virus is is
like all there are any viruses of people
infecting people animals or plants they
require a lot of resources from the host
and this is what i'm going to talk about
uranus
and to do this
we
performed many several genomic screens
for example with using single gene
deletion libraries obese
and also temperature sensitive libraries
of yeast and over-expression libraries
so this covered
more than 95 percent of all the used
genes and we identified
more than 500 genes which affected
tbs your application
we also perform proteomic screens using
uh
for example protein arrays
and also we've done a mass pack based
after co-purification of the
bioreplicase complex
we also perform lipidomics to see
because these viruses also depends on
lipids inside the cell
so this allowed us to identify
and then characterizing several host
factors
and today i will show it to you those
which we characterized in detail
so the very first thing the virus is
doing is that it's
pre-assembling replicas complex this
laptop's complex not only contains the
p33 and p92 viral proteins replication
proteins and the viral rna which is bone
by p33
but it also
records host factors host proteins
for example heat shock protein 70 is
such a protein or elongation factor 1a
and 1b gamma
and also helicases all these are stolen
hijacked from the cell these are then
assembling on the on the membrane
and this is here shown is that in the
early stage disassembly then also
depends on the formation of a special
membranous structure this is so-called
membrane contoxide this is where the er
the endoplasmic reticulum membrane
and the peroxide membrane comes together
based on a tethering protein these are
host proteins also recreated by the
virus and this settling protein connects
these two membranes together and this
allows specific
move of uh of lipids from the
endoplasmic reticulum where they are
synthetic synthetized to the to the
peroxisome this allows the virus to to
create a very special unique membranous
environment lipid environment which is
critical for the virus to form the
bioreference complexes
this is shown here
and
on the very very right you can see the
electron microscopic image where you see
the er membrane and peroxide
membrane the long lines they are lining
up together forming these membrane
contact sites many proteins we
identified which are important to
participate these include sterol binding
proteins
as well as tethering proteins which
connect the these two membranes they are
not fusing they are just nearby
facilitating the lipid transport
uh after also the virus then creates the
so-called replication units replication
complexes these complexes look like here
and shown so it's it's a membrane based
things it's almost like a vesicle
but it has an opening towards the
cytosol so the virus has to deform the
membrane very heavily to allow it to
make a kind of a pocket and in this
pocket the virus replication will take
place
the rna as you can see here is
synthesized the viral rna at the end of
after the synthesis it will be then
moved out of the the
vesicle-like structure into the cytosol
where it will get ancoccidated and gets
ready for
moving to other cells or to other
organisms
here uh i'm showing this on the uh right
you can see now in the box is a
spherical forming in a white piece
you can see that it has a round body but
it the opening is the the dark one on
the top
so this is when it's forming however
device has to recruit
membrane shaping membrane bending
proteins and this is shown here
is the escort proteins these are host
proteins and they are specifically
involved in bending the membranes
in addition viruses like with other you
know proteins as shown on the left and
all this is important
as you can see in the next box uh one is
if uh one of the escort proteins missing
now then the the these vertical
structures are open structure and these
are now not uh
uh supporting efficient replication
anymore
now this is putting it here together so
you can see here that there's on the
laptop peer assembly
in in panel a and panel b you can see
the membrane contoxide formation
and that which which will make the
lipids uh enriched in a
microenvironment for the virus and then
this is followed by bending
the membranes into this vertical like
structures
here
this was the early stage however the
replication also creates a peak
replication stage where you will see
that in addition other
um know
for example the early endosome vesicles
and the retroman complex also like
rooted by the virus
and then also you can see now in the
next boxed area is that the cop2 resides
from the er which is traveling
originally to the golgi but the virus
capturing them and moving them
to the replication organelle which is
the
yellow
bubbles in the in the in the middle
so this is now supporting very very
heavy virus replication one
plant cells can support half a million
to one million
while iron rna production this is very
heavy factory viral factory
and
now i'm going to show a video
and in this video what you will see is
that how the virus is moving forcing the
cell to move
things to the site of replication the
site of replication is if you look at
and to the
left bottom is the purple area
and the green is the actin filaments
which the wires hijack
and
so you will see the red
red
small
early endosomal structures are moving
continuously towards and merging into
the virus replication organelle
you see that this is happening in five
minutes
and
this all these things will end up in the
virus replication
organelle showing how dynamic is this
process the virus is really stealing
very important
resources from the cell
so again this is a very very rapid
process and very efficient using the
actin filaments
okay so
until now i showed you that how many
protein and lipid resources the virus is
taking from the cell
to to concentrate them to the virus
replication organelle
however us also i'm going to show you
that this requires energy a lot of
energy and what the virus is using
i'm going to show you is the glycolytic
pathway glycolysis is using the glucose
as a metabolic source and through a tan
enzymatic reaction it makes a pyruvate
pyrov and during this also atp is
generated
and
the advantage of the glycolytic pathway
is that it very rapidly generate atp and
the intermediates of these 10
reactions are important for biomass
production like
ribonucleotides lipids sergine and other
amino acids are
these
intermediates are being used
also that
no reactive oxygen production is is done
during this process
so the virus is hijacking this to device
application organ as i'm going to show
it to you next
so here on the left you see that from
glucose to the pile with the 10
enzymatic reaction and when we measured
the expression of these proteins through
their messenger rna
in in the
infected
cells
plant says you see the yellow boxes
shows that after four days how much more
you know eight to ten
four to eight times more of these
proteins are produced
uh so the virus is in using the
production of these phase glycolytic
enzymes
and not only in using their
production but also hijacking them into
the replication organelle
so uh here i showed the for example the
aldolase enzyme fpu ip1 and you can see
that the green and the one is now in the
merged image
is together with the
replication organelle which is the blue
one
and this is only happening when the in
the virus in fact itself
we've done this with several of the
glycotic enzymes i'm only going to show
you another one which is the pyruvate
kinase this is the one which producing
atp
and you can see here is that the green
is that the colocalization of the
of the
application organ and p33
and
pyruvate kinase
in cells so the virus is stealing away
these
enzymes
and to see that this is important for
atp production we
modified the
atp biosensor this atp biosensor is
based on a back in e coli
module
which can bind to the atp and during
binding it changes conformation so two
fluorophores are connected to this atp
biosensor and when it bounces to the atp
then now that two fluorophores come very
nearby allowing the so-called fret
and we can measure the threat
and we connected this atp biosensor to
our replication protein so we will
measure atp production around the wire
replicas
here i am showing the results and so how
this works is on the very right is here
scale the red would mean that a lot of
lot of atp is produced
why the
cooler colors including the blue ones
would mean that it's less atp is
produced around the bios replicates
you see that the y type yeast which is
on the top
uh produ the virus replicates
around the voice replicas a lot of atp
is being produced
however when we use a special yeast
mutants which is now temperature
sensitive in the pilot with kinase so at
this temperature now the yeast
is
inactivating the pilot kinase
and no atp is produced and you can see
that the virus in this situation cannot
have the the atp production
we also done this in plants
and
in the top you can see again please look
at the thread
on the very right on the top you can see
in the control that it's a
greenish
reddish color means that a lot of atp is
being produced within the replication
organelle
however in the bottom you can see when
we silenced we didn't use the production
of the pyruvate kinase
in the plant cells now the
the threat signal is blue meaning that
the virus now cannot have a lot of atp
at the site of replication
so to summarize this uh tbsv is
the glycolytic enzymes into the virus
replication organelles we are rules
and this is important for
local production of atp institute atp
production within the vros
and so we had the question what is the
role of this in situ atp production for
the virus and here i'm going to very
much simplify
our findings because of time limitations
what we found is that
the virus
tbsv hijacks helicases from the cell
these silicases are atp dependent and
they are important in opening rna
structures these are rna structures are
important during replication
and
here i'm going to show you the
example so on the left you see that we
have a partial double standard rna where
the top is the black one is the positive
standard and then the hybridized
reductively labeled
area
on the on the left which now makes its
moving to the top of the jail on on the
right so the black line
the ds rna shown there
however when we have the pyruvate kinase
and its substrate and the pep added to
this uh individual reaction you will see
now that the
the helicases can open now this
structure so you can see the single
standard so-called ss rna in the bottom
of the gel
so in summary
we found that this locally produced atp
is being utilized by the virus to help
the virus replication
so uh in summary for this part tps
induces and hijacks glycolytic enzymes
and fermentations and enzymes into the
replication organelles for the linovo
atp production
the advantage is that in this case the
atp is very rapidly generated within the
replication organelles and there is no
competition with the host for the atp
but first come first used so the atp
will be used locally
and also the intermediates of this
reaction can be used for biomass
production which the virus will let us
utilize for its replication
and importantly also no reactive oxygen
is produced during this process
okay
so this showed that how the virus
requires also energy
in the last part of my talk
i'm going to talk about that also the
virus requires transportation
to make sure that things will be
sequestered very quickly to the fact
over applications device application
organelle
so what we found
is that tbsv hijacks the acting networks
it modifies it in in such a way that it
stabilizes the acting network it does
not allow its rapid
changes during infection so it basically
builds uh
forces the cell to build very
very
active
acting network
and
to do this to demonstrate its importance
in what we used in plant is that we took
advantage of the effector proteins from
a bacteria called legendale
these bacteria produces proteins which
can destroy the acting network by
cleaving directing
filaments into active monomers but those
are inactive active monomers
so here on the top we i show you that
the replication organelle the blue one
and the red one together
is against in the merged one the green
is the reacting ones it's uh matched in
the replication organelle
the the application organelle is built
you know uh using this acting network
in the very bottom you know can see the
ref key
and roughly this is the enzyme which
breaks down the actin filament so you
see now in the
middle in the gfp m-turning um
line you can see that it's basically
no actin fluorines are being available
for in the plant cells
and now the virus replication organelle
is not formed as you can see with the
blue and the red is now cannot make this
aggregated peroxisome system
and so this is the bottom one
so we also
shown that when this happens when the
actin is being uh
destroyed by this effector then what
happens to recruitment of the glycolytic
enzyme the atp generating glycolytic
enzymes so here you can see
that in the box the blue box area is
that the atp generating pg k1 and the
virus application protein within the
replication organization
however when you see the next boxed area
and then ref key destroy the actin
filaments
now the
the atp generating pgk1 and the p
statistic replication protein do not
meet efficiently in the cell so no
signal
you can see also this for the pyruvate
kinase or now on the right and when you
see the box is that in the control and
you can see the colocalization the
hijacking of the pyruvate kinase into
the virus replication organelle
however this does not happen when the
actin filaments are
destroyed here this is with the green
circles
and
so this uh suggests that directing
filaments are critical for the virus
to hijack the glycolytic enzymes
and to show this that indeed this is
also important for the atp production
here we
you can use the ref k to destroy the
actin filament
and
so
it's circled here with one you can see
that when
is still directly
filaments no the replication organelle
enlarged
here in the box area is blue bluish
which means that the atp sensor
cannot measure good amount of atp within
the replication organelle this is uh
very different from the top
where you can see that uh the signals is
reddish um
meaning that lots of atp are being
produced within the replication
organelle so indeed the virus requires
and depends on hydrogen interacting
network
so in summary uh today i showed that
the biogenesis of virus replication
organelle is essential for virus
replication
so anything where we would inhibit the
formation of the biogenesis of this
compartment this pathogenic organelle
then basically we put in that we have
advice application
so the formation of these
virus application organelles depends on
the actin network
and also that this allows the virus to
subvert the glycolitic enzymes and this
is important for
for
making atp
and also others i didn't have time but
also
other proteins host factors have to be
converted subverted by the virus for its
application
and this nc to atp production allows the
virus to use this energy
to rapidly
replicate the virus in a protected
environment
so the take home message from today that
it takes a village of host factors and
hijacked membrane compartments to build
the virus replication organelle inside
the cell
and again future research where we would
target these the formation of this
replication organelle
would be very likely a very efficient
way to fight
viral infections
finally i would like to say
thanks to the
my laboratory judy pogany and shifan
who
were running the day-to-day operations
in the laboratory also a postdocs and
graduate students listed here
contributed basically everybody to the
work presented today
i also thanks the
national science foundation the national
institute of health for their continuous
support of my work
and with this i would like to thank you
for your attention and i'm ready to take
questions thank you very much